The David Pakman Show is a primarily viewer
and listener supported independent media program.
I would love it if you grabbed a membership
at Join Pakman Dotcom and we do an extra show
every day for our members.
It's the award winning bonus show.
They are awards we give out, so keep that
in mind.
But they are awards nonetheless.
And you can sign up at Join Pakman Dotcom.
We have a great discussion forum on Reddit.
You can find it at David Pakman dotcom.
Com Reddit.
We are approaching 30000 of our viewers and
listeners subscribed to the sub Reddit at
David Pakman dot com Reddit.
A few interesting posts I spotted this morning.
Oklahoma is indeed trying to return its two
million dollar stockpile of hydroxy chloroquine.
How funny and sad is it that nobody talks
about hydroxy chloroquine anymore?
There is a period of time where hydroxy chloroquine
was being touted by Donald Trump, by Sean
Hannity, by all sorts of random people who
were pretending to know about coronavirus
treatments that had not yet been peer reviewed.
And much like we said at the time, it was
something to look into and study.
And much like many other possible coronavirus
treatments, it turns out it was not actually
effective at preventing reducing the severity
of or treating coronavirus.
And now Oklahoma sitting on two million dollars
worth of pills and they are trying to return
them.
Yes, I have not forgotten about the hydroxy
chloroquine fiasco.
Another user posting that intellectual dark
web users followers believe I am now a member
of the intellectual dark web.
And indeed, there apparently there is a post
on the intellectual dark web Subrata, which
lists me along with.
A whole bunch of people, some of some of whom
I don't I don't actually know, along with
Sam Harris and Jordan Peterson and others,
as being part of the intellectual dark web.
I don't know how my name got on that list.
I also see Sam Harris, his name is on the
list.
And I thought he turned in his credentials
for the intellectual dark web and said he
was bailing.
Yeah, I don't really know anything about it.
I got a bunch of emails saying, David, you're
now part of the A.W..
I've never been asked to join.
I've never said anything one way or the other.
I don't even know the status of the intellectual
dark web at this point.
To be perfectly frank, I haven't heard much
about it for months and months or even more
than a year or so.
The the status of the ID w to me is unknown.
My membership or lack thereof is also nebulous,
so I have nothing to say about it.
I'm as confused as others are.
And lastly, yes, the bizarre stories equivalent
to the Obama tan suit scandal about Joe Biden
are starting.
A bunch of people sent me this article that
was posted on Fox News.com, Joe Biden administration
under fire for removing an Oval Office statue
of Winston Churchill.
Yeah, listen, we predicted this.
We predicted this when we knew Joe Biden was
going to be the next president, which, by
the way, was in early November.
It wasn't January 19th when some other people
finally realized Biden would be president
or even January 20th.
The Republican right wing media apparatus
was very quickly going to go back to all of
their normal tricks, talking about the debt
and deficit, talking about how can we afford
this, how can we afford that?
Is climate change overblown?
And equivalents to the Obama wore a tan suit
at a serious event and that was bad scandal.
So no surprise whatsoever.
And I do expect it to continue.
Join the discussion at David Pakman dotcom
slash